aah
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos and
today i bring you
a character that i didn't really think
that was so popular before
when i used to watch him um early on and
a character that i didn't know was so
dangerous
until a friend of mine
showed me exactly how dangerous he can
be
today i bring you
xm studios
the
lizard one of spider-man's rogue gallery
uh the lizard is particularly
super unpredictable
let's bring it back though let's bring
this story back all right so
early on and i think this was
spider-man's renaissance right so you
have to go to
when um
my good friend
todd mcfarlane
uh took over the book
with spider-man number one
um
i didn't know
what to make of it at first and it was
like the torment uh storyline
but
that's when i found out
exactly
how dangerous
this nine foot
over one ton character
is
the lizard
dot connors
see for those people that don't know
exactly how the lizard came to be doc
connors had lost his arm and he's a
scientist and he was trying to
uh figure out how to regrow his arm
because you see it happen in the wild
all the time with uh with reptiles so he
was experimenting with reptile dna and
you know uh didn't have the proper
funding or whatever and he injected
itself
um but the character always seemed lame
to me
always seemed
you know just like not a real threat and
and how
that they would have him on saturday
morning cartoons and stuff like that it
just really didn't resonate with me
until i picked up that book with todd
mcfarlane
and he was mauling spider-man
uh he struck
real
fear
because of the things that he was
capable of doing and also the movies
with andrew garfield that had the lizard
in it um that spider-man movie was so
incredible because it showed the sheer
brutality of
dot connors
and it it allowed you to go into the
mind of a primal character
that was so blood thus thirsty and
hell-bent on
destruction of humanity because he was
void of it
and
todd mcfarlane brought that across with
his beautiful line work uh and i forgot
who was inking his work and who was
doing the colors but todd
had a a way of doing splash pages and
levels of detail that brought across the
visceral uh effects of the lizard
and that was my reintroduction
into
a character that i truly dismissed
and
realized he was a formidable
forward spider-man that
much so
that he's probably in spider-man's top
five
of his rogue galleries uh most lethal
characters spiderman has some really
lethal characters
but let's get into the statue
xm studios accentuates everything about
the lizard you know from the lab coat to
the tatted jeans
to the whole
lizard look um they keep it classic by
going modern as well
with the lizard and they also have a
switch out portrait the switch out
portrait comes when in that storyline
he's descending deeper into the whole
primal so he starts to lose more and
more of his human features
and he looks more and more like a lizard
so
that's how you get that
aspect of it i won't be using that head
it looks more jurassic park to me i'm
going to be going with the classic look
with the red
textures around the face but the teeth
work and the tongue is incredibly done
the eyes look magnificent
as you can see the cape is fully molded
cape right so
this is not a mixed media cape it's
fully molded kate the tail whips around
beautifully
it's an expensive
expensive
extension of him
and it actually is a
lethal weapon that he uses to perfection
now also his claws xm has gotten his
claws down packed if you can see his
claws his claws his talons
actually stick out pretty far
and they will rival saber-tooth i
believe for uh being as lethal as they
are because he has him on his feet so
you can see the the base the base is
truly done this is a very heavy statue
the base is done very well because the
base is in the source so you have the
resin where it looks wet the textures is
wet and they always do that pretty well
like um
my wolverine my uh weapon x wolf ring
looks impeccable
but this looks really good it looks
disgusting
it looks withered you have it coming out
the pipe here and pulse and he's uh he's
stepping on the uh
the
base of something here down in the
sewers and it kind of dents it a little
bit if you can see like the weight that
he has on it and you can look at the
textures in his chest because you can
see a shirt ripped through and his pants
is ripped and you can see the scales
like like he's a true lizard um i think
this is xm's from the spider-man line
one of the ones that you need to have
because
the story being told from this character
is very dynamic the the poles of the
tail whipping across his body down um
you know this is when i felt xm was in
their bag like his chest his arms is
extended and he's giving you that raw
that they're putting that fear into you
this statue brings that across very well
with the dynamic poles of the arms the
wrist is bent that fingers is uh
protruding out
very
well done the color work is incredible
because you have a lot of different
greens mixed in there with the grays and
the blacks you have dark light greens
so it's just not one color and then when
you get up to the face the face has a
blend of olive
mixed with leaf green to go down and as
different scalings to show that the
mouth would be a little bit lighter than
the actual uh part of his eyes
beautiful stuff great work done and i
think it's an impeccable statue probably
a very underrated statue until you have
it in person but this is the part of the
video when i'm going to ask you to like
follow and subscribe and hit the joy
button hit that download button you know
where that joint button is he also heard
me hiccup because why i have to call
anyway
stick around
see this video in all his glory make
sure you go to iop
that's uh lords of gaming.net go there
and see
all the wonderful stuff that we have
there are opinion writers we also have
uh last word with lord cognito and
ibontes with ty guy travis uh yeah ty
guy travis is there now so go check that
stuff out because he is a great dude and
a welcome addition to the last word
also look at old episodes of iron lord
podcast where myself lord cognito
lord addict and lord sovereign is where
we're taking these weekly
have to watch the show to understand
exactly what that means but stick around
so you can see the statue in all his
glory this isn't some great music and
i'm feeling
a itch
or
a little sand in my shoes
stay
collected
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
you